[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au début des années 70 j'enseignais
l'économie à l'université de Chicago
alors que la situation économique du
pays se détériorerait et que le peuple
souffrait il y avait même certains cas
de famines
j'étais alors très mal à l'aise en
classe j'enseignais à mes étudiants que
tout problème trouve sa solution et
c'était intellectuellement très
satisfaisant mais à l'extérieur on
pouvait se rendre compte que les
conditions de vie étaient souvent très
difficiles parfois les gens n'avaient
pas de quoi manger
parce qu'ils ont marqué juste une toute
petite somme d'argent souvent inférieure
à 1$ j'ai constitué une liste de ces
personnes elle comportait 42 noms
l'ensemble de leurs besoins additionnés
à 27 dollars j'étais très choqué que
tant de personnes souffrent pour une
somme si dérisoire j'ai pris alors sur
mes propres deniers et je leur ai donné
l'argent dont ils avaient besoin
[Musique]
je suis allé voir les banques pour
savoir si elles acceptaient de prêter à
ces gens elles ont toutes refusé elles
estimaient que ce n'était pas fiable et
qu'elle n'avait aucune garantie je me
suis donc porté garant j'ai pris
l'argent et je leur ai donné
je me suis aperçu qu'il me remboursait
vraiment sans difficulté mais les
banquiers n'étaient toujours pas
convaincus j'ai alors continué à prêter
de l'argent dans deux dix 50 puissant
villages juste pour montrer au banquier
que ça marchait partout ah ouais
j'ai ensuite demandé au gouvernement
l'autorisation d'ouvrir une banque il
n'était pas très enthousiaste j'ai dû
rencontrer des hommes politiques des
membres du gouvernement pour les
persuader les uns après les autres
finalement après deux ans d'effort j'ai
obtenu l'autorisation de créer ma banque
c'était en 1983
[Musique]
que vous faites n'a pas d'importance
pour nous si vous savez ce que vous
voulez faire nous vous donnerons les
moyens nous n'avons pas besoin de
recommandations le simple fait que vous
soyez un être humain suffit nous faisons
des affaires et même si c'est la
première fois pour vous ça n'a pas la
moindre importance
[Musique]
[Rires]
le système bancaire aurait pu voir le
jour sous un précepte différent si vous
n'avez rien
vous êtes les premiers bénéficiaires
d'un prêt si vous avez de l'argent vous
êtes les moins concernés c'est ce que
fait la gramin inverser le courant nous
le répétons ceux qui n'ont rien sans
priorité
je connais les membres de votre famille
je connais la vache que vous avez acheté
je connais l'endroit où vous habitez et
vous aussi vous me connaissez parce que
je viens vous voir tous les gens de
votre village que je me connaisse et
c'est très important il faut une
dimension humaine à notre relation
que nous avons coutume de le dire
ne doivent pas se déplacer pour aller à
la banque
c'est la banque qui doit aller vers eux
leurs affaires avec une institution
financière
où se trouve nos 2 millions
d'emprunteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a toujours aimé les défis
c'est dans sa nature
c'est pourquoi nous devons mettre en
place des structures des politiques qui
l'encouragent à relever des défis
dans ce cadre la création de son propre
emploi et fondamental
pourquoi devrait-on systématiquement
être employé par quelqu'un
pourquoi se plier économiquement à la
volonté au désirs d'autrui
pourquoi ne pas faire les choses par
soi-même
[Musique]
nous savons par nos hommes sur le
terrain quand il tire d'entre elles sont
sortis de la pauvreté et que les deux
tiers restants sont en face de l'être
ici
mais les indications dont nous disposons
nous font penser que non seulement elles
vont toutes s'extraire de la pauvreté
d'ici 4 ou 5 ans mais aussi qu'elle ne
connaîtront plus jamais la situation
d'avant
cette constatation change tout au tout
la conception que nous avons de
l'économie de marché et de la pauvreté
[Musique]
regarde les pauvres comme des gens à qui
il faut faire le charité les
êtres humains ne sont pas des animaux
vivants dans un zoo à qui vous jetez des
miettes et qui survivront les
êtres humains ont tous la volonté de
créer
ils ont besoin d'opportunités pour
exprimer cette créativité
[Musique]
ni la pitié il ne demande pas d'être
assisté les assistés c'est les détruire
des notes
pendant longtemps nous avons tous
considérer les pauvres comme des
personnes qui doivent être assistées
alternatif qui permet aux pauvre la
réalisation de projets et par la même
leur intégration économique de cette
façon ni leur dignité ni leur capacité
ni leur volonté d'améliorer leur
situation ne seront annihilés
[Musique]
le sens de la dignité le respect de
soi-même
voilà ce qu'on acquis les cinq membres
d'un groupe
vis-à-vis de mes amis je n'ai pas envie
de perdre la face
j'ai un sens très développé de la
dignité
je travaille dur et tout le monde se dit
que je travaille bien et même si
personne ne regarde la façon dont je
travaille ni ne sait à quoi sert mon
travail tant pis ça m'est égal
c'est une question de position sociale
et ça ne m'intéresse pas
elle agit sur le tissu social et cela
participe à son succès
[Musique]
professeur
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je les ai entendus dire vous ne pouvez
pas travailler avec les femmes les
femmes n'ont pas d'idées elles sont
idiotes leur mari disent qu'elles sont
stupides
surpris de voir qu'elle se débrouillait
très bien et c'est un phénomène que nous
avons couramment constaté elles sont
plus efficaces que leur mari c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui notre activité est
surtout fondée sur les femmes
94% de nos emprunteurs sont des femmes
non pas parce qu'elle nous inspire de la
pitié mais parce qu'elles obtiennent de
vrais résultats
la situation à l'intérieur de la cellule
familiale a beaucoup changé
la femme gère mieux les ressources
surtout lorsqu'elles sont faites
elles prévoient mieux sera mieux compte
de l'avenir non pas que son mari n'en
soit pas capable mais il ne fait pas
l'effort tout simplement
elle est consciente des dangers et de
l'insécurité dans laquelle elle vit la
priorité c'est de créer autour d'elle un
environnement sûr et pour ça elle saisit
toutes les occasions la sécurité est une
obsession elle ne cherche pas une
sécurité précaire mais une sécurité
durable c'est-à-dire avec des moyens
financiers des enfants qui grandissent à
l'abri du besoin et qui pourront choisir
librement leur mode de vie
les maris quant à eux ne pensent qu'à
eux-mêmes vivre au jour le jour ils
savent bien que ce sont les femmes qui
supportent les difficultés de la vie
quotidienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez le cheval qui est allé
[Musique]
le système bancaire traditionnel et nos
institutions financières en général ne
se sont jamais soucier des plus pauvres
sur des limites c'est pourquoi ils sont
restés pauvres ils sont même devenus
plus pauvres encore
qu'ils sont pourtant de meilleurs
clients que les riches
c'est pourquoi à partir d'aujourd'hui
les personnes travaillant le système
bancaire ne pourront plus prétendre que
les pauvres ne méritent pas l'accès au
crédit
il pourrait dire oui c'est peut-être
vrai pour le Bangladesh mais ça ne
marchera pas dans mon pays en raison de
différence culturelles etc et
aujourd'hui même cela est très difficile
à dire les systèmes de la Garmin Bank
sont mis en place dans 56 pays
dans des lieux très différents dans des
situations très différentes et le même
résultat peut être observé partout
dans ce cas pouvez-vous refuser de
prêter de l'argent à ces gens
l'avenir des institutions bancaires va
être forcément différent et rien ne sera
plus comme avant
[Musique]
peu importe que l'on est en face de soi
un pauvre de Chicago ou d'un village
reculé du Bangladesh ils connaissent les
mêmes problèmes ça c'est oui oh oui
ce que nous voulions
mais il y a eu un effet pervers
des gens vivent correctement ont pu
bénéficier des microcrédits
il est difficile de distinguer dans les
pays pauvres ceux qui souffrent le plus
de la pauvreté
ce sont uniquement ces personnes que
nous souhaitons aider
nos critères pour les définir sont
larges
nous considérons que 50% de ceux qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
sont ceux qui doivent bénéficier de
notre action
de cette manière
nous voulons être parfaitement en accord
avec nous-mêmes faire exactement et
honnêtement en ce que nous disons sur
des saisons
c'est très important pour nous
[Musique]
une des choses que j'ai apprises et à
laquelle je n'avais pas pensé c'est
qu'il existe beaucoup de programmes
d'aide consacrés au problème de la
pauvreté
la raison pour laquelle ils échouent
qu'il s'occupe des moins pauvres plutôt
que des plus pauvres
ce qui fait que ces gens qui ont
quelques ressources
sont moins actifs à rembourser les prêts
gouvernementales
car il est concentré sur les 50% des
plus pauvres
ceux qui sont le plus désespérés ceux
qui n'ont pas de choix ni d'endroit où
aller
ils sont plus enclin à réussir leur
programme d'aide
il s'oblige à se réunir par groupe de 5
chaque semaine et à effectuer leur
remboursement hebdomadaire
car ils se rendent compte que s'ils ne
le font pas il n'y aura pas d'autres
possibilités pour les aider je pense que
c'est très important c'est pourquoi la
gramin banque ici au Bangladesh
travaille avec les éléments les plus
pauvres de la société
ceux qui n'ont réellement aucune
possibilité
ce qui en fait son succès c'est
l'engagement et la solidarité
quand on évolue on a vu qu'un bon il y a
très de beaucoup d'occupations parce que
quand on dit il y a beaucoup
d'occupations une femme qui va prêter
l'argent et qui va travailler l'argent
il travaille l'argent il travaille il
parvient même à faire en tout cas
travailler son mari c'est à créer un
emploi pour son mari ça c'est incroyable
on a vu que au niveau par exemple de
certaines familles c'est-à-dire nous ça
n'existe pas une femme qui en tout cas
tout l'emploi pour son mari et pour que
son mari aussi parvient à en tout cas à
être à se retrouver dans le rang social
vraiment ça c'est incroyable
mais nous pouvons adapter ce système je
crois fermement que ce que nous avons vu
de l'agroamine banque peut-être
reproduit ou adapté cependant on ne peut
pas transformer toute la réalité on ne
peut pas cloner l'agglomine banco Ghana
parce que la situation sociale est
différente mais vous savez parfois on
peut procéder à des aménagements du
système
ce qui varie c'est les conditions
d'adaptation qui sont très différentes
en France d'une part la densité des
emprunteurs potentiels et beaucoup plus
faibles
d'autre part
le lien social est rompu très largement
et donc c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
créer des groupes solidaires qui se
garantissent dans les membres se
garantissent mutuellement et finalement
contenu de l'importance du cadre
réglementaire nous ne pouvons pas
financer des petites activités
génératrices de revenus comme au
Bangladesh nous ne pouvons financer que
des entreprises qui sont enregistrées
qui payent des charges sociales qui
exigent du coup un investissement
beaucoup plus important que dans un pays
en voie de développement et
le la technique des groupes solidaires
et plus difficile à mettre en place pour
ces projets plus importants
[Musique]
si le micro-crédit aide les hommes
parler pourquoi ne pas essayer de le
répondre
quelles sont les obstacles
si nous pouvions le lancer sur une base
commerciale ça serait plus intéressant
nous pourrions aider les pauvres sans
aucune charge ce serait un grand pas en
avant
toutes les grandes organisations
d'international et leur millions de
dollars n'auraient plus de raison d'être
vinaigre
devrait être considéré comme un droit
humain
je dis cela pour deux raisons
premièrement le crédit ne doit pas être
limité à une certaine classe
cela devrait être un droit pour tous
le crédit marche comme un agent
déclencheur il aide aux autres besoins
de base il aide à rassembler de la
nourriture il aide à l'éducation à
l'habitat à la santé etc
je dis que la pauvreté n'est pas créée
par l'époque
elle est générée par les institutions
que nous créons dans le monde entier et
principalement par les institutions
financières
tout cela a fait que les pauvres sont
restés pauvres et sont même devenus plus
pauvres encore
c'est pourquoi si vous cherchez à faire
sortir ces gens de la pauvreté plutôt
que de chercher la solution chez eux
chercher là dans les institutions que
vous créez changer la structure du
système bancaire changer les lois de
telle sorte que ces gens et les mêmes
chances que tout le monde
ainsi
cela se produit un jour on peut imaginer
un monde où plus aucun être humain ne
restera pauvre
nous pourrons créer un monde sans
pauvreté et pas dans un futur lointain
lifetime
en fait déjà vivre dans un monde où
aucun être humain ne manquerait de
nourriture de vêtements et de logique
alors ce seront vraiment des gens
libérés de la pauvreté
[Musique]